so our second day of Aristotle we're
looking at jumping from the topics all
the way into another work and we're not
starting at the beginning we're going
all the way to book 6 you might say why
are we doing that well because book 6 of
the nikah mccain happens it actually has
to do with some of the things that
you're talking about in the topics it
has to do with what Aristotle calls
intellectual virtues you can also get a
lot of terminology up here on board and
all these things sort of fit into one
big one big picture and if you have to
say what is this a picture of this is a
picture of the human mind and its
activities
Aristotle begins by talking about the
soul organs you know you know and you
think about that is the mind or the
personality however you want to conceive
of it and what it does and what its
parts are so there's a part of us
there's a part of our way of being that
we share in common with all living
things right what do we do we eat we
sleep we digest you know we grow and you
have to think about any of those sort of
things
Oh God you know maybe your digestion
every once in a while when you're not
feeling right I mean you're upset about
you know how things are turning out in
your stomach I think I shouldn't have
eaten that whole pizza college days so
what else do we do though we we feel
things right we sense things you know
you're hearing me right now with your
sense of hearing or seeing we're seeing
each other you have a sense of smell
which is not particularly acute compared
to other animals you know like dogs and
cats sense of taste actually your sense
of taste is and some ways a bit more
refined
they're animals and then what else tops
right and that comprises a lot of things
but you also feel other things too don't
you what are other things you feel he
doesn't sense a field one leave a
moment's wrap you feel all sorts of
emotions you know like anger sadness
happiness surprise these are some of the
basic emotions admiration jealousy where
you go and all sorts of ranges like you
know there's anger then there's rage you
know those are a difference well the
thing where I can't worry about that
today where you're building our way
upwards you also feel desires - right
you feel all sorts of desires for and
against certain things and you may not
think about your desires that often
because some of them are just sort of in
the back of your mind you know like for
instance what got you here today
on a day where almost everybody is it
has walked in this area just the sheer
desire to sit in a class here about
Aristotle and ask questions about that
sort of thing probably on you guys have
other desires right and there it
competed with desires like the desire to
sleep in how many of you would have
liked to have slept in this morning
except coming at me to class that's one
of the perils of it why are you here
I mean by the end of class maybe you'll
say yeah I kind of enjoyed learning
about Aristotle but let's be honest is
that what motivated you and got you to
put on you know warm clothes and head
across campus with all of you drove in
to drive in and start your car you know
get going over here what got you here
yeah didn't want to fall behind hmm
perfectly reasonable
now that's something that you think
about right I don't want to fall behind
and you'd actually start planning out
what do I have to do it or did not fall
behind you start weighing things in your
mind you know that
it's warm and soft and I still kind of
tired it'd be nice to do that and I
could leisurely morning get up and maybe
make some eggs or toast or whatever it
is go like for breakfast go out for
breakfast you know the diner but let me
think yourself yeah
it's early in a semester I don't think I
can afford to take one of those days yet
maybe later on you're thinking about
things right that has to do their mind
but you're also feeling it has to do
with your desires and share our desires
in common with other animals animals
desire things right how many other pets
dogs cats or snakes spiders whatever it
is your pets have desires how do you
know they do things repeatedly how how
else do you know that they have desires
they pester you right
what kept pestering you for love
yeah a little bit probably the biggest
ones yeah and if they're an
inside-outside can't let me out let me
in you know sometimes both over and over
and over again they express their
desires they let you know you had their
intelligible tea you can actually say
yeah but can actually wants to go out it
doesn't want me to play with it you're
able to read that right you can do that
with human beings as well part of that
aerosol isn't about to say that at lunch
but heard that might actually do what he
calls practical wisdom are any of you
familiar with this term emotional
intelligence there's a famous book that
came out almost 20 years ago called
emotional intelligence and got this
whole movement started it's kind of big
in business and psychology a lot of that
is is actually a matter of whatever
cells come from Asus practical wisdom
and if you notice that book actually
begins with a quote by Aristotle from
the Nicomachean ethics
the right time in the right place that's
right now we're working our way up into
these more intellectual things but the
basis of our being is not just having a
brain being an intellect being purely
logical or anything like that
it's desire it's effective we would say
feelings matter emotions matter all
those sorts of things are sort of
feeding into it to all of us even when
we're talking about the very highest
levels of things like wisdom or
intuition of first principles why do
people actually pursue that sort of
thing because they desire it why does
somebody stay philosophy yeah is it for
some some extrinsic thing like the big
paycheck not a lot philosophers get a
lot of money what else could possibly
motivate you being famous the state
philosophy a good way to become famous
especially needed you to write a YouTube
video that's gonna get a lot of hits
probably don't do philosophy do
something else I had something
outrageous why do people study this sort
of stuff throughout the years my public
do your reading this for the first time
you might save yourself god I can't
believe anybody reads this crap right
yep curiosity okay curiosity is a kind
of desire right and when your curiosity
has been satisfied what do you feel
anyway I feel smarter weight off you
okay yeah sometimes you feel sense of
being more alive if a pleasure pleasure
is also something that
matter of the soul - and all of these
can involve pleasures and pains the
process learning itself can be
pleasurable or painful when you actually
desire these sorts of things for their
own sake that's what motivates you to to
acquire them to learn I mean you can
acquire some of these on wait for other
things too especially scientific
knowledge and skill we'll talk about
that in a moment now let's start moving
out into the realm of the the intellect
the higher part of the soul according to
Aristotle this is what makes us
different from the enemies the other
because we are animals we share in
common with the animals this basis of
desire activity coming basic drives all
this this sorts of stuff but we're the
rational ham remember last class we we
started you know we got a pit at the
very end we talked about what makes it
human being a human being what's
distinctive about you that separates you
from your pets your pets are probably
pretty smart they're not anywhere near
as smart as you you're on a very
different level all this stuff the
intellect we talked about the intellect
we're talking about the part of you that
reasons the part of you that thinks
things out that ways that considers that
says this is the right things the wrong
thing this is true this is false this
goes beyond mere perception you know for
example what would this let's say you
don't know about iPhones what could this
be to you as you're looking at you're
seeing it right that's perception what
can you say about guess there's metal
inside but this is plastic stuff yeah
paperweight
and you might identify it as a
paperweight okay what else can you say
about it as if it's a paperweight should
probably be having you write part of
time looking at something that's heavier
that rectangular white multicolor that's
about it how do you identify this as an
iPhone you're using something like
knowledge you're using something that
goes beyond with your dog or cat has you
can identify this as a piece of
technology right you do the sort of
thing all the time without thinking
about it you make sense out of your
world you make sense out of your
activities you do this in ways that are
usually less than conscious what
Aristotle is trying to do is call our
attention to what's going on there and
how do we do it well
all of that is a matter of the intellect
the intellect is what allows you to
grasp things in their full meaning so
now any anything that you have any sort
of organ or capacity or ability you
could you could develop them right where
you could let it just sort of founder
you guys are developing here in delights
here at Marist because you're in college
was this the only place you could
develop your intellect there's lots of
other colleges there dude you have to go
to college to develop your intellect
there's other things you can do right
like you didn't go to college would your
other likely career path yeah the
military you have no military and that
it's not actually the military they send
you to school right you're going to be
an officer
sir his clothes even ëit is kind of
depending on the lackeys an
end-of-school it's like an OS they call
it analytical but before that we ever
combat area yeah
now a lot of that would be a mirror of
what aerosols comics fuel
what if you went to trade school or you
know vocational technical you'd be
learning things right you'd be
developing your intellect this isn't the
only place that you can do that when you
go into this school
you should look very different coming
out of it right if you put in four years
or two years or however long and you're
exactly the same person coming out as
you were going in somebody gets screwed
somebody you know took advantage of
somebody right either you like when any
to do any work if that's not right or
you went in and they didn't teach you
anything if that's the case then you
didn't develop your intellect they
didn't develop your intellect you didn't
develop if you actually came out and
learn something you have developed some
part of your intellect so what are the
different parts of our our intellect
Aristotle this is not the only way you
can divide them Aristotle divides them
into the theoretical or select do you
think that's a higher part and the
practical when we talk about something
being theoretical what is that what does
that bring to my opinion that we can
abstract this that's good with us
prudence
well actually not necessarily unproven
Cazale it could be but but very often
theorizing is a matter of proving yeah
there are different perspectives and
different importance of it well that's
also quite a practical things too that
that's yeah what else
hopefully I mean if you have a good
well-defined field it is if you're
contrasting something that's theoretical
to something that's that's practical
yeah sometimes yeah especially if we
think about it you know sort of high
level theory you know mathematics for
example everybody can say you know one
plus one equals two and if somebody
doubts that what can you do there's one
thing there's another thing that come up
right that's not intangible is it you
can actually season II might say be
tricky about it but no these are two
things but you know go a little further
in mathematics and started introducing
X&Y and stuff like that and talk about
slopes okay now you can kind of
visualize it a bit you can look at
things in the real world and say yeah
because there's a Hill that's got a
slope you know they go sledding if the
slope is higher and go faster I
understand that but now we get to even
higher level we start thinking in terms
of calculus rates of change and
measuring those and limits and now we're
talking about things that are very
intangible okay there are such things in
calculus like objects of rotation yeah I
mean we could go to all sorts here some
of them we can get we can again head
around and see others we're sort of
abstract think about economics law of
supply and demand has anybody ever seen
the law of supply or demand you can see
people buying and selling things making
crisis you can't actually see the law of
supply and demand eat nothing do put it
in the textbook so yeah there's a
certain degree in intangible
we get to higher levels again that can
play the practical is like to think
about artwork people who are great
artists what actually separates their
work from other art that's kind of
shocking is that something that you can
put your finger on e to this part of the
painting that's it right there that
brushstroke that did it it might be
something intangible their expiry
procore matters think about this
theoretical matters why do you study
theoretical matters
yeah sometimes impact the practical
second to impact practical thought they
may have applications yeah but
oftentimes you study them for their own
sake because you're interested in
knowing about XYZ maybe if you study
biology then you might be able to go on
and become a doctor go on you know
medical school or you might you know
work in a laboratory or something like
that but that's not what studying
biology is you will get out that's some
of the discipline of biology about and
that's not what the part of your mind
that's working with that and learning it
it's really focused on as a matter of
fact if you do that if you only focus on
practical applications you will not in
fact thoroughly learn the theoretical
thing that you're studying
if you turn everything into a matter
with the practical intellect you will
not be good at whatever it is whatever
theoretical thing you're trying to learn
you'll miss some things because the
theoretical intellect is concerned with
things that we study you might say for
their own sake so we can know about them
also according to Aristotle it studies
things
it pays attention to things that don't
really change again mathematics somebody
says one plus one plus one is two today
there's three today but it'll be two
tomorrow what would you say to them
dude you could say no use of your nuts
why would you say something crazy like
that mathematics is you know one of
things we like about this is fairly
unchanging physics okay models of
physics have changed over time as a
matter of fact aerosol those own ideas
about physics that now we don't actually
buy into because you know people like
Galileo proved some of them wrong and
then people also prove things wrong
about later things but the idea is that
there's some constants if you're
studying this this thing this discipline
if it's a matter of the theoretical
intellect you can tell you've got things
right when things are agreed upon and
you can count on them being the same
right is that the case in everything in
practical matters it's a lot harder to
come up with perfect rules that make
sense of everything does that mean that
we don't have knowledge that we don't
have any sort of nobodies you know any
better off than anyone else know there
when we get to the level of particulars
when we're dealing with things that have
what we call pragmatic and practical
applications things get a lot murkier
than they do is higher you know more
pristine levels the practical
intellectus is not so concerned with
understanding for its own sake it's it's
interested in understanding for the sake
of something action how to make
something how to do something whether
we're doing the right thing whether
we're doing the wrong thing those are
the sorts of things that the practical
intellect is constraining so now think
about this have you been doing that sort
of thing your entire life yeah the
question is have you been doing it well
or have you been doing it poorly or
somewhere in between have you been
working about trying to get better these
sorts of things yeah
put in a very practical way what are you
actually doing here at Marist College in
terms of what it is that you're studying
not just in this class but all the other
classes that you're studying I know some
of you are undeclared at this point that
you will
majors probably by the end of this year
this business this academic year or at
least you know by next semester you know
some of them maybe philosophy hope but
you will be studying something that you
want actually get right that you
actually want to understand that might
be something for the theoretical implies
there might be something of the
practical well it could be practical in
a certain sense well it could be
practical in two senses one is there's
no better if it's done well there's no
better training for your intellect than
philosophy classes philosophy majors
actually um you know like the Graduate
Record exam the walk the LSAT exam among
the highest classes why is that
what cuz it trains your mind in ways of
other disciplines tend not to so I could
have a practical application I'm going
to be a philosophy I'm gonna study
philosophy so I can be well on the LSAT
because that would be practical right
could be it could be serving some sort
of practical and in another way because
you need this class in order to make it
through it right you have to you have to
take intro because it's a required class
so you can graduate eventually you can
what you're more interested in stuff so
there could be a pragmatic aim there too
yeah this could be practical in a sense
if you actually started joining us and
start wanting to know didn't play we'll
say that instead of thinking about now
we were actually dealing with things
that are from
and this other country until it gets
gets engaged now you notice I've got all
these are the terms up here what's
what's going on with those well
Aristotle talks about five kinds of what
he calls intellectual virtue virtue is
not a word that we use an awful lot and
we're not gonna study it very much in
this class we did that boring ethics of
us we'll touch on it here and there you
know when reading Cicero and Augustine
and some of these other people we're not
going to study study it for its own sake
what a virtue is is a kind of excellence
a kind of doing things well things
functioning the way they ought to so
let's take a few examples this is true I
suppose you could say as the virtue of
being able to you know show up well on
the chart
whereas some of this other stuff give us
like this color chart you know not so
good also this chalk is dense feels good
in the hand this colored chalk is flimsy
and I hate working with this bad sound
that's a very trivial how many of you
are musicians in any sense you play an
instrument
what do you oh those are you gonna be
like a songwriter because you couldn't
pick any to better for for composing he
had on a guitar those are pretty much it
you know what makes a person a good
piano player
okay that's that's sort of on the back
end that's what turns them into the
piano how do you know they're a good
piano yeah there's there's a lot of
intangible things of that too right
you like listen to somebody like that
just doesn't sound right you know you
can think - what's wrong with my playing
well I mean your tempo is will have hit
the wrong notes and then there's
something else about you playing I've
heard people get those sort of reports a
good piano player has a certain virtue a
bad piano player might actually have a
certain kind advice now is that a matter
of the intellect yeah that's a matter of
the intellect that's a matter of being
able to do something well what Aristotle
calls technique or skill or art they
ever play an instrument how many of you
like to play anything athletic something
some sort of game so did you have to do
any development of your skills what
happens if you don't develop your skills
well what happens to the people who say
I don't want to do drills I just want to
play the game in your experience yeah
and don't they I actually fall behind
they may actually start out with a real
good you know original Talent
Tamarack by the way it can be can be a
killer for people people start out
talented they're like I don't need to
learn anything from anybody art students
are the worst for that they somebody
tells him in high school
oh you're such a talented artist and
they come in and I know this was a used
to work for art departments they come in
and they're like I don't need to study
any of this art history that's
completely you know waste of time I
don't even need to like do drawing class
because I just want to paint and then
the art teacher will be like no you
actually got to learn drawing before you
do painting because the skills from one
the other they feed into each other and
what happens to the people who have
talent the donuts are actually doing
development of technique they follow me
hi everybody else we didn't actually
have so much talent they they for us
don't that because what they're doing is
they're developing their practical
intellect the other person just kind of
sitting still what about the theoretical
employed does anything like that happen
I can tell you that it does because I
coasted through high school and actually
larger front of college I was very smart
you know I got like high test scores I
read a lot of stuff I didn't read what
the teachers with assigned to me because
I was kind of you know smart smart right
you know the other and I were doing what
I'm going to tell me what to do so what
I found is I didn't actually learn a lot
in high school why not because I didn't
actually study the things that I should
have studied that they assigned to me
because I thought I knew better and then
I got to college and I went to I didn't
go to a place like Marist I went to a
much you know lower grade college where
it wasn't it wasn't hard to get by and
to do well and I didn't really start to
apply myself until I got to graduate
school and I realized man if I actually
want to learn stuff and I want to become
a better person if I want to have an
excellence of mind I better start really
studying and I did and then I was really
surprised by how much you get out of it
before I'm sorry you don't read whatever
I wanted to read and you know hand in
papers and just get by I'm gonna be
well this is a matter of developing
excellences and that's part of what
you're doing here through through your
studies you're developing excellences of
the theoretical employment or the
practical let's look at your subtle
scheme now well let's look at scientific
knowledge first he has his term at
piston a in greek yeah this debate can
be translated as science it could be
translated as knowledge it can be
translated I think as well as like
disciplinary knowledge would be an
example of this mathematics or physics
or biology it's a body of knowledge and
it develops by beginning from certain
starting points and then reasoning about
them so think about when you were taking
all we took biology that's right high
school what did they give you other than
a place to set and a teacher in front of
the classroom and maybe some things to
dissect what was the biggest thing the
most important thing they gave you for
the class or maybe you buy it the
textbook right now that textbook wasn't
just a whole bunch of things you know
throw it all together cannon you know
humble jumble in no organization right
started out with some very basic
principles what was the first things
that you learn about in biology do you
remember exactly why did we start with
cells most basic thing exactly so you
can begin from starting points and then
you build from those and some of these
things you know you're learning in
science are doing deductively you begin
from certain principles or premises and
then you reason or argue about that
others you have to kind of you know do
experiments one thing have you do
experience why they have you do some
things do they still do them we into
pigs or rivers and frogs some sometimes
it makes virtual things do they don't
like us
so it's not just like learning about
it's obviously theory do you see it yes
that's very important being able to see
examples of things now imagine that you
didn't have a textbook and you had to
figure this stuff out on your own and
you're really interested in what makes
animals tick what might you do yeah no
but it would it only be one animal or
would you have to do there maybe the one
animal you pick was unusual
I would think different because I mean a
fish why does the fish breathe
underwater but then okay can so let's
say you start out with that you can see
the fish do fine underwater and other
animals that fall in the water after a
while they die all right they're not
doing so hot and you're wondering how
does that yeah how are they able to
breathe so you get a lot of fish and
pull them out and you look at their
common structure and you notice they
have these weird things they would call
gills and maybe start dissecting them
and its are theorize that's what
Aristotle calls induction you look at a
lot of examples and try to figure out
what the common element is and we do
this in a lot of things you use
induction to figure out how to behave
with other people remember back to when
you were a kid on the playground what's
what's be animal what's good about
playgrounds first you get to play right
hopefully what's bad about playgrounds
it's great beings yeah sometimes bullies
and scraped knees my hands please come
together yeah other kids are most likely
to be their worst problem on a
playground and you you learned about
this over time right let's stick bullies
for an example you get bullied sometimes
maybe you pull the other kids you see
other kids getting bullied let's say you
say I don't like this bullying stuff
once a by now you've worked
you're systematically yourself I don't
like this bullying stuff I got a knock I
got to make sure that this doesn't
happen to me then you could start from
some sort of deduction you know your
parents told you certain things like
always stand up for yourself you think
yourself okay dad says always stand up
for myself that's a starting point
that's a promise yeah this is a case
where I'm being bullied so that means
it's a case where I should stand up for
myself so I know I need to stand up for
myself and you should think about what
does that mean
probably I should pop them in the face
there's a sort of leap there well that's
a deduction what if you actually like
sat back and you watched kids on the
playground and you've watched kids being
bullied and then you've watched which
kids kept on being bullied and you also
observed kids something happening and
then the kid not being bullied it you
know you start saying what's the common
elements over here I guess maybe the
bully gets transferred to another school
or they get tired of it or somebody pops
them in the face you say pops me the
face seems to me the thing that tends to
stop bullying the most and then now you
get bullied you're like well I don't
really like being bullied on this guy in
the face you've done what Aristotle
calls induction you've generalized from
experiences and you also said because if
I don't do they happen look at all these
other cases where you know this this kid
just says stop it
don't do that or you're not really
bothering me or you all of all that sort
of things that don't work on bullies
I'll give you my lunch money you look at
all these different cases
generalized from experience right do you
do this with other things
who should you take classes from Paris
how do you know
what's up rate my professor so what is
rate my professor and there's a couple
other sites out there doing this yeah
what does rate my professor get the
score is that does that score by itself
everything you look at them what
comments why is the Komets manatee
because other students who maybe someone
or may not be some order to you have
taken us and conspiracy kids also
exactly you're carrying out induction
like without realize now if you're doing
that in a sort of high-level way you're
acquiring scientific knowledge this is
what goes on a lot of the disciplines
scientific knowledge can't supply itself
with its own beginning points according
to Aristotle these can actually be
provided to us by an argument or even by
necessarily induction we have to sort of
get those with to realize those and
that's what he calls due tuition or as
tune of reasoning or noose which
literally just means mind your intellect
and some people have scientific
knowledge but they don't actually have
this so they can do just fine in that
science but they can't tell you why
things are the way they are about
science at the fundamental level this is
where you actually get the starting
points of the fundamental level so if
you ever asked your biology teacher
yeah but why does cells do the things
the way they do why are there cells in
the first place that's a higher level
question and your biology teacher might
say hi shut up and read the textbook
quick quit asking so many questions
you know it'll take a philosophy class
if you want to ask questions like that
philosophies kind of a dumping ground
students who ask too many questions
places well that's because your teacher
didn't have this and they didn't have
this they probably can't supply you with
that doesn't mean you can't develop it
on your own it gets a little bit more
interesting
what does it - yeah that's what wisdom
that means having both of these having
the starting points and having
scientific knowledge about important
things things that don't change
Aristotle's you know was interested in
astronomy watch it - Aristotle arguably
does somebody have wisdom because he
possessed the starting points but he
also worked on the scientific knowledge
now is that all we have as a matter of
fact a lot of our life is concerned with
the practical making or doing rather
than just looking at we're thinking
about and we inquire about this - don't
I mean do you just do everything from a
haphazard random we already know you
know when it comes to classes selecting
class is a trivial thing is that you
actually like usually how many of you
use rate my professor almost the whole
class so you know just selecting a class
you don't just sort of jumped into it I
imagined that if somebody said to you
yeah I was in this class of this
professor but I had it's terrible but I
didn't do any checking up on him even
though that's your own problem right you
created that you should have thought
thought that through that's a question
of using the practical intellect how do
you know what major you should make a
lot of you are you've either decided
recently and you might go change
I know you're still in the process and
deciding is that a question of the
theoretical intellect I don't think so
why are you majoring in the finger major
yeah I've done it already it's
interesting to me I get it
so you know that you actually like it I
hope all of you end up liking your
majors so much yeah because they're
gonna prepare me for something that I
think foresee like a future profession
yeah you see it as a means to a end that
you desire any other reasons you might
be good yeah and then we tend to be we
tend to like things that we're good at
right pleasure to thing maybe somebody's
told you hey you're good at this you can
probably make a living at it that's
another reason to do that sort of thing
these are all practical concerns if you
find yourself in a manger that's still
suited for you don't stay in that manger
there's plenty of other things you can
study there's jobs available in all the
different fields you don't you're not
tired just because somebody told you to
study business or psychology or think
whatever you want that doesn't mean that
you have to study that or if somebody
pushed you into philosophy you'd really
like to study business study business
because that will actually make you
happier which is what the practical
intellect is in part concerned with your
own good the good of other people what's
better
what's worse figuring out these sorts of
things what will get you towards your
goals now the practical intellect deals
with two different kinds of matters some
of these are about producing something
it could be a product like what does the
musician groups music breath that you
can listen to it could be you know music
that you actually record and now you
dissolve a CD right or it could be that
you're the piano player
the reception piano players the
reception is the person who nobody
notices but it makes the place a lot
nicer right because there's music play
music what is a what does a factory
worker produce whatever it is that their
factories is producing you know if
they're assembling iPhones iPhones
let me ask a few other questions what is
uh what does an architect produce built
trucks structures yeah not what it is
just the plans really it's a that and
then we have contractors to do that but
in Aristotle's time
the architect was the top person and all
these other people would be doing their
skills their productive activities
underneath them what does military
science produce this is kind of a tricky
question
yeah well technology is something
different the art afford what is the art
what is this what's its prop what does
it suppose to produce if I have the art
of word you don't have good soldiering
the right technology but ultimately
antibiotics supposed to winning the war
victory right what is a physical trainer
supposed to produce a fake human being
and good Planet Fitness
you know it's down the road least
according to their hands it guys you
walk around they can't tell you what to
do that should make your body better go
to the doctor what is the doctor
supposed to produce
yeah notice what the doctor you have
somebody who has some scientific
knowledge well that's really a
productive art the doctor is not
interested in germs and stuff like that
for their own sake they're interested in
actually
can you feel better right oh maybe
they're interested in making you feel
worse
no enable doctor now for all of these
arts crafts pills there are certain
standards within them right
you can tell what is good music what's
bad music if I if I were to play the
piano I don't think I would make very
good music you would probably make much
more you know harmonious music that I
would you have that actual art or skill
I am a good rhetorician I you know I
don't I don't turn it on too often but I
can convince people with things if
you're going to sales you do want to
become a good Rhenish if you're going to
manage convince people of things produce
conviction that's a that's an art
Aristotle actually voting on a book
called the art of rhetoric it was the
first scientific study of communication
so I never you are a communication maybe
you should probably read their songs my
brothers you learn a lot of stuff
what else are productive parts anything
that we call Fine Arts those are all
productive arts there are standards for
those as well right sculpture painting
pottery meetings I suppose what else do
you think
yeah that'll work yeah this is a friend
of art or a dude on terms of
blacksmithing and I'm forging you know a
lot of blacksmiths around these days to
do things through diet presses but it's
the same basic together right we're
going to have a die press operator you
actually go to school and you learn how
to do something I have a friend actually
supplies swords not a huge call he's
getting something he's been unknown now
does that cover everything well there's
this realm that he calls practical
wisdom this is a little bit more
intangible - this has to do with what's
good for you on the whole and if you
wanna think about it contrast the art of
medicine is a productive art it tells
you if you want to heal somebody how to
heal them right it also gives you the
opposite to it if you want to kill
somebody with medicine or drugs or
something like that go go ask a doctor
how to get partners because they'll
probably know what you know what would
be a good you know dose for an overdose
or something but can the art of medicine
tell you whether it's a good idea to
heal this person or not think about a
sticky situation you're a doctor think
about this for guys ever want to show
house you know faces all these ethical
situations should this person be healed
or not well he does really is
our parents he has a hard exterior
houses somebody who's concerned with the
practical wisdom when it comes to
medicine actually all the people under
you are two again and that people over
him forget his friend who actually
because of the chief the question of
whether you should or not heal somebody
let's say you here's here's one that
came up in there somebody is a it wasn't
a dictator he was a war criminal
right yeah made me see that episode the
guy had engaged in atrocities should he
be healed or now or would it be better
to use medicine to sort of
surreptitiously and kill somebody like
that that's not something that the art
of medicine can actually tell you the
art of medicine just can just tell you
what you want to yell somebody here's
what you would do how you should
practice medicine aside from its
internal standards the ethical questions
that's a matter of craft goes
okay I've run in the ambulance
- like locally and at home and a lot of
times similarly to doctor obviously
young to me these like subconscious
decisions when you pick up people that
you know say like Arif it's so our
language very good people and you know
they are because they're identified in
the town in the community and then say
they're in credit for us and you have to
perform CPR it's like are you really
giving you your 100% or you not because
you know that they did this thing to
this child in your town and you may know
of or not you know they're eager to face
with that yeah very difficult questions
that come up in medicine also you know
another art or skill that we don't tend
to think of this would be like policing
criminal justice right that is
productive of something what is it
productive Oh security safety or perhaps
justice to figure out how to do that
well requires a different part of your
mind
it requires practical wisdom so what is
what is practical wisdom it's the
capacity to judge well in things that
could go a lot of different ways that
are up to human beings to judge well in
terms of moral values it's the good in
the band or the good in the evil the
just and the unjust what's fair what's
unfair now here's what's really
interesting Aristotle thinks that you
can have rules for these sorts of things
but the rules can't cover every case and
in order to be able to figure these
things out well you have to develop a
kind of sense of judgment the capacity
when you get too sticky cases like that
to be able to figure out what the right
thing really is and some people have
this when other people don't some people
are practically guys other people are
they're practically foolish and I mean
the good news is if you're practically
foolish you can be reined away from that
and if you don't yet possess practical
ism you can develop it but you actually
have to think a little bit about what it
is that you're trying to develop in
order to
do that it's not going to be something
for the haphazard this is why we have a
study of ethics in the first place
because it's not enough just to like
it'll want to be a nice person or a good
person you have to actually you know
work on your mind on your intellect on
the parts of you that engage and that's
sort of judgments you've got some sort
of defensible reasoning why in fact
you're giving the cpr not giving the CPR
putting this person in with the other
criminals in holding or taking them out
and putting them in specialty area yeah
I'm just going back to the actual like
yeah it was it was one of the guys I
forget the Australian guy if I remember
right who killed but then later
throughout the series he like has an
entire like emotional breakdown the fact
that he actually murders yeah there are
some ones I'm saying by the way that if
you possess practical wisdom you will
invariably always every single time come
to the right you know realization if you
have it up more often than not you'll be
better at that than the average person I
would say that then what's that
Australian guy's name
chase yeah chase okay
I would say that chase is somebody who
was sort of a to having from Asus I
would say that the person who probably
nacho is the closest to having furnaces
is houses best friend the guy with the
dark hair was his name
Wilson yeah yeah I would say he probably
and Explosives houses are really
interesting series in part because it
was set up deliberately to introduce
ethical problems you may not realize
that you may have but it's all about
like solving puzzles right that's a
matter of the scientific intellect or a
matter of art or skill or technique but
really the things that made house the
most interesting the things that
actually make most narratives
interesting are these moral questions
that come up now what I won't leave you
remember when we were looking at Plato
Plato was really concerned with this
question of knowledge right who has
knowledge who doesn't have knowledge can
you do you have knowledge when you have
virtue what is virtue all that sort of
stuff they don't make any of these sort
of distinctions we really love knowledge
all into one big bushel Aristotle's
making distinctions here if you say
scientific knowledge or disciplinary
knowledge is a whole different animal
and actually is a different part of your
mind then does practical wisdom that
does art or skill so if medicine is down
here and mathematics is here but the
good life is actually here these are
different types of knowledge and they
would have to be treated differently
Plato man made some mistakes by putting
all these things together not making
distinctions than with an aerosol
oh that's a very good question in a
person who is well integrated yes a lot
to all work together and ideally there
are Spears and aerosol effects aerosol
thanks ideally you're going to have both
practical wisdom and wisdom wisdom and
you're gonna spend you're probably not
going to spend too much of your time on
practical matters you're going to spend
a lot of your time
contemplation of higher things I'm not
so sure that we'd all be attracted to
that
and I'm not I'm not so sure he's
actually got that right I think that
sometimes figuring out like what makes
people tick that might be higher if that
I know for me maybe this is this applies
to some of you if you're going into
business or you're going into psychology
or history or things like that it's
probably at least in part because you're
interested in people all right we're
communication and communication majors
even fashion I think ties into this as
well
fashion is about communication you're
interested in why people do things the
way they do are a lot of you interest in
that sort of thing yeah why you know
what makes people tick what makes a
person a good person bad person all that
that's a matter of integrating these
different kinds of knowledge so you can
see you're right the other thing I'd
point out is if you're screwed up in
this way you may actually like have
scientific knowledge but you'll use it
wrongly what helps the application or
you may have you know skill over
technical use a problem think about well
here's a good example here's a danger
for those of you that are going into
business marketing or sales should you
treat every one of your relationships
transactions involvements as if it is a
sales opportunity
got right there are certain certain
lines you shouldn't cross
don't make everybody into a client now
you could be really really good yeah
what it is that you do convincing people
to buy whatever it is not everybody
needs to buy whatever it is that you're
selling and what would help you figure
that out not the argument or technique -
yeah you might be so good at it that you
really it like there's so many brought
up before you enjoy doing the things
you're good at practical wisdom is what
would tell you hey hey you don't need to
sell things to your to your your wife
your husband your father-in-law
mother-in-law brothers sister maybe you
can turn the sales pitch off her for a
little while and enjoy Thanksgiving
right and the same thing would be over
scientific knowledge practical wisdom is
needed in order to integrate the
personality so a very important question
what is practical wisdom for hairstyles
won't located a little bit lower than
thism maybe if it were meaning I would
actually put practical wisdom at the top
so that's something maybe for you guys
to think about where would you put these
different skills how would you rate
these different abilities or capacities
that you actually have and then you're
working on and your development right
here at Marist College absolutely walk